Robert asks I know viewers get a lot out
of your new show but what is the most
significant experience that you get out
of it Robert that's a tremendous
questioned I appreciate it you know for
me I it's kind of weird right I have
this whole chapter of doing video
blogging on an everyday basis that I
enjoyed so much in it for five and a
half years I think the best thing I have
is like being back in the game a game
that I love I mean I love running
businesses but doing this video blogging
thing it's just a lot of fun for me the
other thing that really i get a lot out
of it a lot of you hardcore old
schoolers remember mot and those kind of
things I mean d Rock Show this show Andy
and their zach and just unwin and and
then here we are in by the way an d Rock
he loves it like all clean show the
table d Rock he like was like scared
that you guys would be like I admins
he's a little polished for me at times
but like because thing I get is that
here i'm in atlantic city by the way
little fun fact real quick pre-show to
this sunday nights miss america from
eight to nine i think i'm getting a lot
of like action so make sure you DVR that
and check that out but here I am in
Atlantic City what would be going on
right now I would be sleeping or doing
email but here I'm jamming there's kind
of like team like family thing I love
that so much i'm creating something
creating something is special and so I
appreciate you guys caring enough at
enough scale to make me want to continue
to do this and build something them
there's a there's no substitute for the
feeling of accomplishing something and
that's what I feel is happening here so
thanks so much uh thanks for watching
this episode question of the day this is
very simple I'm keeping it basic keeping
it very basic what state do you live in
you keep asking questions and I will
keep trying to answer them oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe